so if i do this if i jump off this
[ __ ] building then i'm gonna break my
leg where a young person that doesn't
have that fully formed goes i'm gonna
try to jump off this building and as an
adult you go but you're gonna break your
leg and you'd never practice that so why
would you even do that well having
raised so many kids i can tell you
that's there are
large varying degrees of that right and
you know that because you let alex my
brother do a lot more stuff like with me
you don't let me do anything because you
say that's because no because you're
stupid
nobody said you're in therapy right
well i just sent her back yes yeah yes
is your wife in the industry at all
uh well she grew up as a skater a skater
in detroit and oh really punk scene and
then um moved to california when she
graduated college and she used to edit
snowboard videos
for uh snowboard publications so she's
definitely yeah she's in the universe
and she's a skater too she still skates
yeah really yeah wow so the whole family
what's the embarrassments of her own
kids really sometimes well they're
better at it now but when they were
teenagers and we would go travel and she
would bring out like we would be in
paris and we'd be skating around town
and and she'd bring out the
skateboarding mom
oh my god so people would just see a
flock of hawks i know but but it was
always like mom what are you doing
we're all scared what's she supposed to
run alongside
that's so great though yeah yeah they're
there
you have videos of the whole family
skating together yeah yeah yeah that's
amazing
i love that and and uh is there if
there's only the one the 29 year old is
the only one that's really competing
he's pro yeah the other ones um are
good skaters in their own right um but
they didn't really want to they didn't
choose to make career they went to
college and they're all pursuing other
what is your 29 year old's name riley
riley i love that name that's my my
other kid's name is riley um
do you feel that he has a lot of
pressure being tony hawk's son like
undue pressure he he actually quit
skating for a while because of that
um and how do you really how do you cope
with that well in his early teens he was
shying away from it
and
he started doing motocross and between
his mom and and i we didn't really have
the resources for him to be doing
motocross seriously to get him to the
track and get all the gear because
that's a that's a full-time
life when you say resources you meant
time you have time the money
sure yes we have the money well uh yes
we had the money yes i would say there
was a time when i'd damn the money but
he was much younger and he wasn't riding
a motorcycle so yes but this is a
lucrative business you're in a very oh
no absolutely i'm not saying that at all
i'm just saying that the resources was
the time like you know when you
moto kids that's what their families do
they they're living like they're driving
them out to all the races and tracks and
stuff like that and he he was enjoying
it but but it was just hard and he
started talking about
he started talking about
being sponsored getting a career doing
it and
and i had to have a heart-to-heart with
him and say you know riley
i appreciate that you want to do this
and and i think that you're pretty good
at it but you already very good at
skateboarding especially for your age
and i feel like if you wanted to focus
on one thing you have a better chance of
making a career doing this and i know
yes i'm your dad and i know but i feel
like you already have created your own
style you do it in a totally different
discipline he's a street skater um i'm a
ramp skater i'm a vert skater and so i
just said if you want to if you want to
pursue that i'll stay out of your way
but i think you have a better shot at
making a career of it
and i think he heard me uh
yeah i would imagine in any you know i'm
in show business there's always your ego
is always being kicked
and and he has an added it's hard enough
to compete
to try to be the best to try to be
noticed but with that name even though
he heard you he still probably has to
he does yeah but i think that the other
the other side of that is that
skateboarding is so diverse
in the ways that you can make a living
at it so what is the difference between
a skateboarder or vert or whatever so i
grew up skating pools right right then
pools
sort of evolved into ramps half pipes
right and that was always my my chosen
style through the early 90s street
skating became more of a
when you jump on the rails and stuff on
the rails because it was more out of out
of uh
desperation because there were no skate
parks
so
so kids just took to the streets and
they figured how to make the street
their skate park
so that happened all through the 90s
that was his era of growing up skating
and that's hard for me to watch you know
i'm i i'm walking around santa monica a
lot and i'll see these kids just at
venice they just jump on these uh
banisters and they're taken false like
horrible horrible fall so when when all
the skateparks closed and street skating
was i was doing it quite regularly and i
went through a whole summer where i i
sprained both of my ankles severely and
i thought if i want to keep skating i
can't think i'm going to do these
handrails and things i'm going to have
to keep i'm going to have to stick with
what i know which is which is vert and
even though that was not excess as
accessible i just kind of focused in on
it and and kept doing that my son riley
just went on to become a masterful
street skater but to some people what
you do is scarier to drop into like
those
yeah there's some irony there because
when you when you're riding a big uh
radius like that what we call a
transition all of that all of that area
you can just slide down when you fall
right when you're jumping down a set of
stairs
you can still slide down you can sleep
downstairs i see that all the time when
i watch ridiculousness i see all those
clips all the times of all the kids like
going down the stairs and just eating
[ __ ]
yeah which
also contains corn
[Music]